in mice they actually showed when you
take healthy young poop from like a
healthy young mice and put it into Old
mice who are on the end stage of their
life it can actually extend the lifespan
of the old mice that's crazy because and
if you think about it the stem cells are
a similar principle you're replacing the
ecosystem why does your whole body's
Health improve when you're just taking
someone's poop and putting it in your
colon It's because the ecosystem that it
provides it's a good bacteria that
signals it sends and we know that the
gut communicates with almost every organ
in your system and so if you have a
healthy gut it creates a healthy
ecosystem and similarly when you
replenish these stem cells it's creating
a healthy ecosystem that's getting
depleted and it also helps to obviously
repair the gut lining reduce
inflammation and all that to